sorry everybody welcome to Monday male
how's it going you guys can clap come on
you dicks he's got oh my god I say we're
very very excited that a Gabby Hannah
from the gabbie show on today's stream
KOCO we're gonna be played some Mario
Kart 8 and before we start quickly I
just have to say something
Gabby blew my mind really quickly about
the United States of America and a
certain person hidden in the map I know
we're just I know we're here to all play
video games and have fun but let's
switch the geography for one second all
right explain quickly to the people at
home what's going on there's which we're
gonna show in a second so the map it's
holding in the frying pan is Kentucky
Fried Chicken and the state is Kentucky
it's it's very easy state I can find on
a map is Kentucky it's crazy it's crazy
alright so show the Mack just I don't
think just hold up the thing Oh alright
this is gonna blow your mind yes this is
gonna blow Bleus miss a sure bra just
watch it all right pull these up all
right so look at it quickly
there's no passwords anything okay can
we just see this terrible I'm focused
God son of it there you see there are
the states look there it's a chef it's a
man I always his face you know I'm
talking about anybody see that man you
guys look up a map it's crazy it will
blow your mind then you're welcome hey
DJ cake so da what's up yeah you know
what Clark's declaring no I'm sorry we
don't have all the people unlocked but
you know that's uh you got it you can't
get there yeah exactly you gotta earn it
all right so you've never played Mario
Kart which also blew my mind my mind has
been blowing twice we've been playing
for 30 seconds hey shady fringe what's
up hey Chrissy 87 its Gabby that's right
it's Gabby
Thomas says she own vine
and that's it the linkage alright so
here's how you play it's a racing game I
don't know how much do you know my Mario
Kart I know that you can throw bananas I
love that's what I was gonna flip it's
yes it's a banana throwing game yeah
it's mostly bananas mostly I don't know
the majority of these characters I know
this is Wario right yes this is their
kid right uh oh I have no idea you're
already ahead of me you already I mean
this is a guy from Sesame Street this is
a Jason junior the killer yeah exactly
Oh today's shirt is I only go on the
internet once David but for 24 hours
there we go she hates Mondays and I love
the Internet we both love the Internet
hey Monday's all right here we go take
your guy I'm not sure how much the guy
really matters in this game what do you
mean I feel like it matters David do you
know who matters the most
also her friends Alex and David are here
they're gonna join us in a few minutes
Omar Mario you're just gonna go Mario no
that's so I'm gonna go Luigi
and here's why actually I actually
didn't plan this but do you want to see
a hilarious show everyone said don't
forget to dress oh I love you to stroke
peanuts shrimping trope sure peanuts uh
which controller oh this the control ok
yes was this guy he looks like a minion
oh he does kinda look like a mini Lizzie
I don't know lakitu who's this dude like
it to all right so wait what did you do
for Thanksgiving did you go home I was
here and friendsgiving friendsgiving i
love it we all brought a dish and it was
really really what dish did you bring
I made some ladies and gentlemen okay
I'm gonna be lame and go with peach just
because that's not lame that's great
peaches I think she's a peach is the
best I just say my knowledge I went home
right and my friend become crafty and he
grew a mustache all right that's sexy
grandma said you would take it sexy not
on him
I kept saying hey God you look so
familiar you look like somebody I know
and love shut up yes look at this this
is what he looks like
that's him why would you do that to
yourself he was like I don't look like
Luigi I was like you totally do yeah
that's incredible well so I'm gonna be
Luigi okay my friend craft
I just did that dance showdown show this
won't be the last time you're gonna play
we're gonna play
yes I did fully dressed as Mario and I
don't believe any of this I just had all
this what do I do just I just hit it I
don't die don't screw you no no no I
didn't know that matters to me you know
when you're when you're as great a Mario
Kart player / as bad as I am tires
aren't gonna help me I need a different
brain I think it's - I do whatever
whatever says the guy who's Terry
terrible of Mario Kart yeah why do they
I said this one there we go that's
that's pretty intimidating to be honest
hmm all right flower a not very
aerodynamic but hey that's you oh wait
wait - timeout no I don't know I've no
idea
all right let's just start easy okay
start with the basics yeah all right
here we go
tell me about dance showdown what is
dance showdown um it was a dance
competition show where it was basically
Dancing with the Stars with youtubers
and at one point I did an entire dance
as Mario and Luigi with my friend Matt
and it was super super embarrassing and
I had to do it three times and get a
clean run but so wait do they have dance
me were you doing like the the thing
where he jumps what did you quit Mario I
did you do it to the Mario music no they
gave us like royalty free music oh there
we go the Internet so I think it's a a a
is gasps do you know how to start David
is gasps oh my god peach not Luigi okay
Shanna's gasps right trigger is gonna do
your drifting when you go around corners
oh you get the question mark boxes that
gives you the things right and I think
you shoot those win oh god what are
these littles mushrooms left left bumper
shoot so those are tert that's like
turbo
wait what's drift drift is right trigger
like a round corner you can count slider
on corner is there way to go faster uh I
mean well yeah there is you cuz you have
the you have the mushroom so if we hit
the left left bumper will activate when
your mushroom oh oh this is or left or
left trigger by the way left trigger
left
oh that's what all my mushrooms are gone
oh yeah you only had three you only had
three mushers I'll use one oh you did
yeah I thought oh we got a Wyatt
this is great I'm like watching someone
see snow for the first time this is like
amazing it's not snow it's just like
jeez what this is changing my life wait
am I even pressing go wait what am i
holding a mushroom for so you can also
you could throw the mushroom or use it I
think you can throw it or use it put
away bro I think left trigger I think so
but it's gonna make them go faster I
think oh oh did I just nail you
something you Sabine oh no it gave it to
me and I already bumped into something
this is really sure peanut says stay on
the road I'm trying dude it's tough are
they talking to me or you I have no idea
oh go snowflakes what does that mean
smut sponge Mac I'm gonna blame this on
peach she's the worst you're a sweet
boombox though look at that base system
oh yeah exactly you know I probably
should have turbo dough around a
freaking embed no wait what kind of what
kind of car do you use what's your
stereo system in your car let's talk
seriously I do I do not do cars I Drive
a Toyota Corolla yeah girl honey I do
not know anything about what I don't
know what horsepower is Oh actually it's
not like a real measurement is that
supposed to really measure horses I
think some like Beth you're smart
I always thought horsepower just meant
you had a Mustang I wrecked them a lot
so I don't think I can put gooses at
least Gabi has excuse she's never played
before
yeah I have no excuse I should be better
at this game but I'm not so deal with it
I don't want to say you don't know how
you're doing is I'm afraid to take my
eyes off a peach so you could be doing
really amazing or not Bantam you spit
this game it's incredible what's happen
it's a crutch yeah you are I want fire
you're or on shrooms I don't know which
one
wait what's this gold just go this is
good or bad
good Weiser says can I do an
interpretive dance of my crappy gameplay
dance like oh man I can't really dance I
can do the running man though check this
out I don't know well you can see this
kit like this is not this gonna work
is this gonna no that's not gonna work
wait where can people see dance showdown
is it out yet uh yeah you can go to
[Applause]
Bethel pay for it Oh rocky butch goes
this Gaby great job let Beth play now I
don't think so
the rut oh I did the running crotch
you're right that goes hemorrhoid master
by the way why would you name yourself
hemorrhoid master unless it's a cry for
help I'm saying you go see a doctor
maybe I'm just saying or there's a cream
out there I think that takes care of
that maybe or a spray or something a
cream is also really good for exactly is
that true yeah I actually put the
hemorrhoid cream in the bag at Conan's
hands because he's kind of old good
thing this isn't live so I didn't say
that live that's good that was
absolutely awkward yeah as adorably
awkward that's my dancing I'm the
adorable awkwardly dancing person you
got to wait hats why was your first
Mario Kart experience um I I could have
done better but I think I could have
done worse for sure
okay it's all random it kind of just
comes up randomly right exact um you
know what maybe we should play something
out of the banana Cup okay Hannah Cup
which is an intervention I made up where
you put a banana in a cup and eat it out
of a cup okay what do you want to play
here there's dry dry desert don't plains
three don't it means three all right
do you really California so you're for
Pittsburgh California is obsessed with
Donuts I mean I was doing even if t-ten
do they call Pittsburgh p-town they
don't call it that
No thank the peeper what are they
covered all right I was just trying to
come up with a cool name for thanks bird
you tried ya pit the p2p bizzle well you
told me you got the pit the pits bizzle
yeah Michigan Michigan they just call
hell on earth or no there is salvation
there's also a climax Michigan and
people keep stealing the climax sign on
the highway with the arrow that goes up
there either I've never in my life
driven past climax Michigan the off-ramp
where there hasn't been balls spray
paint and underneath the arrow or just
the side has been going one of the tip
Wow
I think you know climax Oh what would I
name it class oh I don't know that's a
good question I don't know maybe they're
just having fun like somebody in the
government we think we got a shortcut we
just said ah I think you did a shortcut
I'm not sure uh you're very close to me
now you're ahead of me now you're ahead
of me yeah
yep but now see I see you right in front
of me there you're so small I think well
no I'm behind you but it's nothing
that's right trigger do right trigger it
does the drift you know what we could
make our cars faster I think so really
we can make our car if you feel like
you're ready I don't know you got it
although she's just starting oh man Wow
yeah that was me hey removes
what's up there's a paradise Michigan
and Christmas Michigan know people
Amisha are just lazy they're just yeah
they just went through a dictionary and
picked words is it really whoa you're
just weirdly aggressive you know sorry
such a beautiful hour play on 50cc
yeah that's why I'm terrible at this
game answer Laurie
Sandman is the director of weights
Emmitt is direct inspector hit that's
crazy used to be married to my number
one kate winslet she's my number do you
have any celebrity of exceptions you're
just allowed to sleep with if you are
you dating anyone
boy okay there we go guys wit when
you're with somebody you can have a
celebrity exception mine was Kate
Winslet always key wins and you're not
allowed to have anybody is your
celebrity exception wait okay i doesn't
need to draw your attention the fact
that my hair was gold first i guess oh
my god it's beautiful like swaying in
the breeze there i feel like the problem
with luigi Mario's they always have hat
hair you know because they're always
wearing those hats well you're right but
I'm just saying if there's a good nice
photo-op or something maybe maybe they
need to get what if they're gonna go to
is something fancy they keep their hats
on I guess they're plumbers what do they
do
do they really go to France or what if
they're going to the Palmer Awards what
is it going to the plumber Awards
and they need to take off I don't know
should be everything else playing Just
Cause 3 although I will be playing it on
Twitch I don't know if we'll be playing
with Conan though battle creek my
hometown was the worst raw schuiteman
what are we done we're done that's great
wait were you worried about to say um
did you ever see the conspiracy about
like do you know there was like the
original Mario and then there's Mario
yeah like the old Mario games right was
like Donkey Kong oh is this the one
where it's all it's really the only one
is the real life and like his peach like
left him or whatever and got with Koopa
no I've never seen that one did I just
say a way nerdier thing mine's pretty
nerdy it's lime line of Mario and like
the original Mario is actually Mario's
grandfather and the Donkey Kong in that
movie is actually a grandpa crank or
cranky Kong whoa really because if you
like remember the first Mario wasn't a
plumber
he was jump man Mario and he
was a carpenter holy girl and now he's a
plumber or him and his brother of
plumbers oh my god that's awesome yeah
and it's like a whole thing and there's
just like all of this vengeance between
the families because the original Mario
Jumpman Mario had kidnapped King Kong
yeah watch it's really good that's like
The Sopranos like the original Sopranos
is actually Mario actually Mario this is
very nice
so the one I saw was uh so it's all the
ones so only the first Super Mario is
real life okay but and the rest of them
are all his fantasy where he's trying
that one right it's all a play yeah so
he's trying to like get peach back but
it actually she just left him and for
King Koopa her Bowser Bowser she left it
for my actually oh that's what it's
right right he left it for his brother
right right so yeah it's like if you
look at all of the translations and
everything yeah they're translated
loosely into English with the actual
translations talk about Luigi and like
Luigi and Peach are actually in a
relationship and they have a kid ah and
then Rosaline shot to the heart jump to
the heart but Mario is a sociopath
that's brutal
yeah that's - he has to be right no yes
all he does is punch you just punch his
back in the head yeah yeah those bricks
are people do you really what is it the
because the coins are souls no is that
what it is like you're releasing the
souls or something who became he changed
how insane did this stream get the
people into the bricks and it says like
you changed all the people into bricks
like God he's breaking the bricks he's
killing all the people this is amazing
it's so bloody and terrible I love it
Oh finally I wash it here's the craziest
thing about this whole thing you've
never played Mario Cart before and you
know how this does Super Mario
unbelievable unbelievable so great so
great no such beautiful I we're not
making this up at all this is intensive
no look it up it's the game theorist you
can oh who the says I heard that -
about the bricks being people yeah they
are people it's in the manual it's not a
secret if you open up the game manuals
it's just a manual yeah that's a real
it's not like a theory I'm gonna start
reading these manuals good guys oh my
god let's wait it - this kid said I've
begun
like Conan can't stand being around
exactly I'm super annoying what about
the shrooms those is the guy q sure no
that's true all right wait wait let's
play some kind of Luigi situation here
for in honor of our our theory so no
Luigi thing oh my god maybe there's no
Luigi thing no there has to be that's
rude that's straight-up rude
there's a Wario thing even Mario's oh my
god there's no Luigi thing holy crap it
might be right your thing might be right
did you ever see the one where Mario is
missing it's Luigi's castle at the end
of it like you finally find Mario and
like Luigi you can read his Diaries of
how much he loves Mario but Mario always
deals on these clothes about him and
then he saves them and the entire game
literally ends with he saves Mario and
Mario just stares at him and nothing
happens there's no thank you so much
they literally just stare at each other
in disdain
I can't even handle how intention good
god he's a crazy person my good lord
cool well should we have Alex and David
come in yeah alright guys you want to
come in and play yeah you just said we
love playing with the most
unenthusiastic voice I've ever heard all
right here we go does that mean I've so
no you said you take all right let's do
this you guys have played this before
right I don't know all right
all right would you want to use the
gamepad oh sure right here so you guys
could trade off if you trade off I don't
want to say hi to everybody about
introduce yourself say hi every my name
is David I'm Alex well done thanks
everybody thanks hello Gaby's fellow
cabbies friends alright here we go let's
do a little multiplayer I like to bring
the member where he goes we turn this
one what's that alright here's this yeah
you could turn that all right so let's
turn it like this yeah he already has
the advantage yeah that's good so click
to grab the that's right well maybe you
guys can try it off alright so let's see
if you hit
oops no wait hippie hippie go back you
hit a alright you're down there what's
one of mine oh yeah you are I agree now
uh Alex I think you're up your upper
right blue baby blue yeah your blue I'll
be the same and I think your pink and
your green your green cause I'm great
agree wait what was that silver guy oh
that's a battle up here
are you sure I'm green yeah I think
you're green are you great yeah you're
green oh wait yes so you can go up if
you want to be silver Mario you can go
what's he do
I think he's I don't know he's like the
evil t1000 from t2 maybe he can let me
[Music]
you could also be him don't you dare
okay you're gonna be me just kidding
just kidding all right though we haven't
unlocked those guys yet I'm gonna be
baby luigi coz he's adorbs he's adorbs
they're baby peach oh set youp you whole
I says oh the the silver Mario is super
heavy all right little care oh wait is
that bad no no I think you could knock
and might but you know you're powerful
though you're gz slow bit mighty we're
you know we're gonna make these cars go
real fast why I want my car to look cool
so I wanted to be all silver there we go
ooh they do have all silver ones look at
the dumb wheels the dumb wheels
okay Metal Mario where impersonate the
other players who can win the game
exactly that you're that did anyone see
Terminator Genisys yes
but I want it too it looked cool cuz it
had that new that other t1000 was back
right yeah yeah silver wheels there's no
silver are you sure those are white
where's our white wheels little plane
like it's maybe gonna go fast Oh
actually I'm need this fan here we go
alright cool alright we're gonna go
we're doing we're gonna go fast go fast
we're gonna go fast
I don't know frantic mode is this is
crazy alright what should we play it
which we play like a plain one on the
second ya sunshine Airport alright
because we all sure do you guys did you
guys travel
Thanksgiving or no I know you did
where'd you travel to Minnesota
Minnesota oh I like it
there we got Whizzer snow in Minnesota
on Thanksgiving yes yes nice and you say
were you at Frank Frank friends again I
was did you have some the margaritas
Gabby's Marguerite allow to I'm not old
enough
oh no I had Fanta Veni no it's good
do you call them something special like
a gaba Rita or something Gavin Rita's I
should have no AG a burrito is a burrito
we just get rid of Rita
oh you can't drink that I guess you
could put in a blender though baby so
hey all right so hey I know it's faster
a is a is gas right trigger is drift
left trigger is use your items have you
guys ever had a gobbler eat Oh
what's a gobbler eat because it sounds
like a turkey burrito oh my god that's
awesome yeah the entire it's just like
basically Thanksgiving dinner in a
burrito oh that's awesome I love that
whoa wait where do you get it from Mad
Max I've heard of that I think what I
did was an okay how are you guys so good
what do you mean I know the words we're
the worst dude how do I shoot these
things off
hey brother Todd what's going on yep
this is what you get for staying up late
twitching last night oh my god what what
just happen bananas no I just blew on
your hey Jose 971 it's an ant theater
what's an e a theater call me pendejo
wait wait wait wait wait it's a frog
I've never had poutine by the way
because I ran poutine it's like grits
gravy
it's like gravy and french fries right
oh that's so great it's like a it's a
kbecque quaffing comeback did you that
Thanksgiving poutine
in the Netherlands Oh Tokyo Tokyo pips
had a gobble burrito had one Florida
turkey stuffing gravy potatoes the whole
lot Oh Lord is they routine a dictator
probably that's food yeah and he's also
delicious you can do if you hold if you
hold the trigger you kind of drift I
love when I had that fire go drifter
roof how'd you do that
bougie gravy oh my god gave the engineer
poutine gravy french fries and milk
curds I'm really small wait Alex do they
have cheese curds in Minnesota I know
that have them within Wisconsin cheese
curds aren't the squeaky ones but if you
like the Feres itself have you guys ever
had cheese curds no it's basically like
like little destroy cheese yeah yeah
it's deep fried cheese right no big
mozzarella sticks except the yellow
version but of all right in a ball and
then they squeak when you chew them yeah
yeah that's weird if you like cheese is
really like nails on a chalkboard squeak
I'd say it feels on chalkboard tasted
like delicious fried cheese then yes you
probably never tried nails on chalkboard
that
oh brother Todd made it to work on time
glad to hear it
we're making you hungry off-camera I
haven't eaten lunch yet but I'm not
either every Thursday here at the
Catholic Warner Bros commissary they
have Thanksgiving
except Turkey 7030 every Thursday it's
impossible not to game oh my god that's
brilliant it was delicious oh I'm
totally doing that when you get married
that yeah I mean if it ever happens
which it won't but I'm doing that and
then Cheetos just straight-up cheater an
open bar that's the best I'm not a big
I'm a classic scrunchy guy you're not a
puppy no no people who eat pups are
their lives yeah no exactly
there that's no
I can't do it why cannot for the life of
it who got third Oh Clara says hey tell
Conan the gray I'll be late with a
delivery for the red fox day he'll know
what to do thank you good I got I won't
be pulled into your spine
she don't weddings to Shady fridge Oh
cheetah westerns really God's made some
I didn't win by finished no 11 I'm
literally almost lost but not last but
not last but not last weight can beat
you that hard
hey it beats you pretty hard wow it's a
pretty hard beating game well thanks
game beat you extremely hard uh what
games do you got what's your favorite
game to play model or is it just
straight up my don't worry fair - yeah
probably have to go to call of duty 2
call of duty - I like duties conquest
that's called duty to be call duty as
well which Call of Duty though what I
don't know that's what you say what did
you say JD's conquest yeah what does
disco you're like familiar with these
games really like the Super Nintendo
Atari Sega Dreamcast
well actually I barely so much that you
didn't play n64 Mario 3 no I was poor
guys it is it's time for a song
let's do oh this is fun let's do a
little too many duties no she loves -
what did you hear our whole crazy
discussion on the whole theory of Mario
hmm yeah I heard it
oh you were just on your phone the
whole time you call me rich as your
friend as Gaby's friend David doesn't
even care I was reading about how
excited I like Abby to be here by the
way tell the wingman story how bad a
wingman you are this is terrible it's
not a wingman Gabi asked me to be here
we all right on the go you so
youtube.com slash the gabbie show okay
okay okay okay so basically Gabi anis 11
so about telling stories okay Gabi you
tell the story basically out of
celebrity crush that's the long story
short you need to go watch the entire
video yes he actually revealed
now their secrets meet in the video but
I told him to wingman for me he goes up
and talks to this boy who I'm like in
love it was a man come on give him some
credit it was a man he was emotionally a
boy I'm like in love with from a TV show
and doesn't tell me what he's gonna say
because the gone don't worry I'm gonna
wingman for you comes back tells me oh I
talked to him he's not interested what
does that mean the opposite of a wingman
that you were really interested in like
wingman does oh so embarrassed literally
cry wait did you really cry I cry
oh so bare my god oh no he use their
glare at the party I didn't want to be
there anymore
Oh oMFG pardon my letters it was like a
big plot okay okay when I asked him I'm
like my friend has like a thing for you
do you want to you want me to go talk to
her he's like no sorry have a girlfriend
I don't know if he made up something or
whatever and then I'm like okay I'll
just tell her that you said she's a
oh he's like and he's like if you
do that I'll punch you in the face yeah
this guy was a douche oh my god yeah so
he like Floyd Mayweather oh yeah you
need to watch the whole video because I
tell the story way better when you're
not trying to win yeah that's crazy
gosh I've never trusted David again but
now every time he's hitting on a girl
like babe are you ready to go we
actually hit on the girl that's you and
where's a good wife and I made this
point earlier but that is actually what
a true wingman does was protect you from
terrible guys so really he did do a good
job we I don't even know how does a
wingman situation work like I thought
that's how they cut it they kind of
David yeah oh I don't want to get I hate
people
no we're giving David a lesson yes no
wake me up casually it's okay so - oh
that's Gabby she's so cool you should
talk to her why you set her up you set
me up you set her up right second grade
to say hi my friend really likes you I
was never wingman in second grade
I don't know what school you do but yeah
you're supposed to be like talk like
talk casually about Gabby's
accomplishments like Oh Gabby oh my god
you get a 10-second conversation she's
accomplished what are you talking about
me I'm David so means I love semi-kids
because he loved that's a pretty good
impression of for a second I thought she
said tell me Alex have you ever been a
wingman no honestly though I appreciate
it what would be alright let's say you
were Gabby's winger alright what's your
strategy let's talk strategy probably as
terrible as David's to be honest I would
just be like hey we just pointed out a
way David strategy was terrible you know
you would you know but you could trust
David it made me trust him I didn't ask
him David we have wingman David later
said hey let me win right like honestly
like I knew that like what was gonna
happen I just wanted to be in that
YouTube video with him you were thinking
ahead to the YouTube really well plan a
better mark very calculating very
calculating exactly all right what about
a little character I hate oh yeah okay
let's go back let's go back he's the
word exactly we also don't have to get
you to play Mario Kart we can play
something some other Nintendo game
luigi's mansion or something I never
played that it's pretty fun okay you
wanna play that sweet I guess yeah he
really give me the game fact if he lets
us in it's uh it's like this game oh
well not I do like this yeah this games
fun because it's uh one person's a ghost
and the other three people are trying to
capture the ghost the ghost is Chinese
Oh kind of like pac-man yeah yeah
exactly you can really go
it's really fun wait do we all play it
to get like we all play yeah we all four
of us oh my god let's do a be the ghost
yeah absolutely we hold on let me see
here if I can I don't can you look at
all the little people that guy ask Mario
Kart drunk driving is that even possible
what's us can you can you go drunk ah I
guess you could be drunk and play the
game yeah you could be drunk and play
the game but you can't just like pick a
drunk okay I don't think so that maybe
is in the adult version like Mario's
drunk uncle it's not like okay no but we
should write Nintendo yeah we should
write Nintendo that's a great idea guys
let's do it nobody could capitalize on
all the no no this game all right here
we go alright so let's see everyone oh
you know what we can't play this game no
the remotes
I don't you want to try to hunt down the
remotes all right we'll talk to the chat
for a second Oh Maddy
I know God O'Malley hates when I throw a
curve balls at this tree oh wait no
they're right here they're right here we
got it we got him a mouse you got him
look at this see we got we got there'll
be fine O'Malley's O'Malley got the the
Kickstarter Pebble watch oh here let me
I was wondering cuz I really want one
but I I would know what I like to use it
for some save your might extra middle
line and check email hold on yeah Wow
impressive
O'Malley is Apple should hire O'Malley
to juice all right here we go you're
gonna be Conan that's a really good
you're gonna be the green guy I don't
know it really is look at his cheekbone
how did they do that everybody's really
good at they're gonna be you're gonna be
Jordan alright alright here we go oh
yeah I can't believe I get to be Conan
there we go
he's right that's fine yes he walked by
to it he's so tall he's really tall he's
very tall he's like a head with legs
it'sit's crazy he's buff - he's like
taller than that bobblehead you guys
have already do you want to be the ghost
yeah okay here yeah all right here's how
you play oh it's gonna tell us how to
play but basically us three are against
her oh we're not gonna be able to see
her okay so you moot you turn it
sideways right oh yeah you guys got it
ready all right so then you shine the
light with with one right now you got
your flash it always a certain amount of
batteries so you got it yeah that's how
we burn her yeah all right and you're
gonna start vibrating you'll vibrate the
closer she is to you the more you'll
vibrate it is kind of like a slender man
ah
you're the ghost so you're gonna be
moving it you're gonna play on this so
so we can't look at what look we can't
look at this that's you yeah so you so
you this is your blade so look at the
gamepad screen there we go yeah all
right so here we go you kind of you can
cut you guys kind understand I choose
kind of like sidestep all right so you
just have to go and try to touch us
that's all you have to do that's so hot
exactly it's explaining it right now
there we go it's the creepiest noise
ever oh can turkey says yeah Luigi's
Mansion Slenderman so she's gonna see
like this the entire time and we're
gonna see like at night right yeah so
we're not gonna be able to see here you
can only tell by the vibrations or if
there's a light we'll be able to see her
that's really cool yeah yeah it's
awesome this game is great camp the
snuggler yep we're playing now we're
playing Nintendo Lin all right - kind of
side steps I don't really use it but
this oh yeah sigh frog says this is
slender man and pac-man's baby that's a
good expletive axe serious yeah it's
still explaining all right
yes Jordan got married cheer creeper Oh
keep the snuggler this is great you
shouldn't touch this game all over touch
it heavily all right let's skip this
let's go this is great I kind of
want to start playing video game thank
you
oh I'm starting a gaming channel Oh
finally finally let me know I'll come on
that gaming channel let me know all
right here we go
hit the ghost of your light all right so
I'm green uh-huh here we go remember oh
yes Oh get her I thought I made you be
get hurt why are you fading cuz well cuz
you're you're being burned you got to
run away oh my god
Wow we're great at this oh no she got
you I spoke too soon
now has he done is he dead no no we can
revive we can revive him by by shining
our light on oh yeah
you're getting my back I'll bring him
back up
get my back get my back get my back oh
you got hit by the robot oh you're back
it's a battery go get the battery oh man
she's close she's close oh crap get her
get her
oh we got her we got her we got oh
that's freaky question
it goes count looks like an easter egg
but I guess it's to make it mad at not
so scary hey joy carnage hey everybody
hey John say hi to everybody everybody
say hi to John what's up he's alright
all right let's go play let's go again
yeah see to your life telling me I'm
here he's our user probably works at
witch awesome yeah he's the creative
director for twitch hell yeah carnage
when you coming back
carnage and Fred Durst flippin came and
played they're like best friends it was
really fun
I know we played what did we play I
can't remember now
kara is fun we did play Mario Kart yeah
yeah there we go and I think we played
like some kind of black ops or something
but like on the Wii so it was terrible
here we go who's purple me get your head
in the game yeah I got tag-teaming nice
job nice job two people left come on
guys
baby my back get my back David just
hanging out by himself man David hey
your what's up good to see you David
save us oh just another somebody good to
see it's been a while
subtag meme macho oh nice nice yo David
just likes to hunt
you're like a predator you like the solo
hunter this game way we need more et we
can't hook up the Atari its art which
set up yet when we do we play black ops
and we you which look really good so
we're like seven years ago it looked
great for 1993 that's good oh man this
is like what I'm this is like a grudge
match the robot thing is kind of rough
yeah cuz like you like I can't catch him
guys
oh nice we can play a different one
where you run away you want to try where
you just run away none or not as a ghost
this is one where you just run and we
all try to chase you that's fine all
right let's do it yeah it literally will
be packed the house really fun though
that's great I love Nintendo land is
great vertically don't tell me how to
live we you black ops on we yeah
at Mario chase what's ope original
alright so here you guys pick Pixability
just with the pointed out there are cool
on our car alright ready oh man I
haven't seen Jessica Jones in here it's
great oh my god I hear it's amazing it's
a show on Netflix about like a private
eye jessica jones who used to have super
powers so she's so super powers Beth
yeah David Tennant Beth's crush I please
the bad guy the purple man there we go
so this is the same thing only now
you're gonna run away we're gonna chase
so we don't know where you are we're
gonna have to try to find you exactly
what I need to call of duty terms so
here we go they don't know when Opie
means are they ever on the internet its
original overcook piece over cookies
original poster Alex worst wingman ever
says mr. Deadpool right here we go guys
let's focus up focus up all right here
we go
go you gotta run you're supposed to run
run somewhere I'm so lost
alright we're just getting weary gotta
find her and chase her and I think if
you press one of the buttons you'll die
exactly
alright so I'm I'm blue call out your
colors who's green I'm green David's
great Alex is purple and Gabi's running
we don't know she is no we have no idea
I'm gonna split up oh I'll see her yeah
you'll see no no no she's not a ghost
you can see her no you can only run at
this speed oh you see her wait what
color she in well I'm gonna go far away
from her
gabbi's face look at how concentrated
she's game face she's got a game face on
Draiman this is the tenderloin we're
playing Mario chase I smell something
up up where where is she I don't see her
she's now I'm in green I'm heading
towards blue Oh anybody see her anywhere
close
she's sneakily camp the camp it out
green door early Klaus who's this
Green's getting further away she has
that yardage it says how many yards you
are closing in now you're close oh man
now you're in yell you're in yellow I'm
so far away
oh I'm closing in that green this green
closing down on green I'm green headed
towards yellow
I think she's liking maybe she's yes oh
I'm so close I'm so close
now she's spot not she's away I don't
see her anywhere
I think she's on me you know you can do
whatever you want come on oh man we
gotta get her this green don't even seen
her oh now she's running away
yeah oh man where is she dammit you know
you're supposed to stay away from us
yeah I get to the center yeah yeah go to
the center I'm in blue let her
where where where this way wait why are
you all got our Ewing you're so cute but
color yeah purple turn her off so we can
just ha I'm coming David split up split
ups okay / foam coming to purple why you
still want to be with me coming to
purple hey wait if she in blue nothing's
down blue she green I my heart is going
down is is looking at you I don't know
well you look at how far away you are oh
man we didn't see her this oh she's up
there we're on green screen up far up
far on to the right
it she's up there she's right no oh my
god Wow she was great at that yeah yeah
that was all right what you were
literally never even close
I don't even see you once that was sad
damn it
see here all right here we go let's see
where she went you went to the yellow
jelly babies we have to find ya ants
we're staying on yeah
oh man look I look at where I am I'm
always the opposite of you wait did she
see all of us like on a mini map yeah
yeah yeah she could see where we are a
lot of that while you sitting yellow is
the entire time damn it love it this
Java oh man all right here we go oh my
god oh you were on the hunt at the end
there when you were saying are you in
blue usually like ten more seconds ten
more seconds
you got a stamp what can I get we're
gonna get it this time right here we go
continue play Oh awesome
that's what I said all right we share
same same thing or different thing same
thing same thing here we go Big E says
I'm a Michigan band with as many people
as possible so please bammy all right
ban ban away I wish is your command
ah he said I'm gonna Michigan band is
first by as many people as possible so
ban me yes we played fallout 4 last
close gamer great what's my favorite Wii
U games this kid snuggler
ah oh man that's a good question zombie
use pretty fun
[Music]
[Laughter]
I mean Super Mario Galaxy is great here
we go I'm Alex
yeah like he's dead every time this is
Gabbie from the gabbie show also in the
inset box it's great all right here we
go here we go I'm gonna run for I
haven't seen the civil war trailer yet
are you guys conflict fans I have seen
it oh yeah I saw that it looks good
because iron man's it oh yeah that guy's
awesome
all right here we go guys I think we're
smarter here we go oh man
closing it I'm in blue yeah we're much
smarter now closing in far away I think
she's headed to her she's not I think
she's headed oh my god she's running far
away from me guys I'm closing in they're
closing it where are you you're in
yellow yeah
Oh what did you just get somebody just
get something yeah would you just get
[Music]
all right I'm headed towards yellow I
think she's in yellow look out
I think she's in yellow I mean yellow
she's close I think she yellow headed
towards red
oh she's headed towards towards right I
see her she's on the time I scream look
I'm out right now just that yellow now
she's not back to right I see her eyes
here we go here we go I'm gonna top top
top ring of red up she's going down
right click your necks rock here we go
here we go that's left again laughter go
after this here we go oh man I see her
she's headed towards yellow come on
how'd it tore down that oh my god no
she's on the top we're young oh god I'm
so close every calorie count
I'm coming so close oh man I'm losing it
I'm gonna head her off
I've gotta cut up oh man George green
their head towards green I'm cutting
over the top gun over the top here we go
[Laughter]
how's it tense all right you want to be
now you wanna become good here we go
let's see how good you are now you
running I think we were smarter we had a
good game playing this time it was when
I overlooked a thing and helped so much
it's not even fair when you really gave
my bag no I overlooked overlooks oh you
went uptown yeah oh that is smart what I
wanted like one of those I let him from
like the red area yeah yeah there's
there's like towers wherever oh look at
this see it up at the end like that
though hey I think it's just oh look at
that look at that you were on me in the
center was crazy that was hilarious that
was that was great boom see look purple
was going in well done well done
all right here we go it's up to you
Danny I got it here we go you're good at
chasing are you good at be in shape no
maybe we should do it different yeah
what's - we're gonna do we're gonna do -
there's thick mud in this one wait you
were able to like pull back and look
higher I went up like on a higher like
peak and I saw yeah there there's pieces
so this one has mud somewhat will slow
you down and if you go over a bridge
after you go over it it'll disappear and
so you I think are really great I think
your green then your lower left the
gaming goes well juni 119 deca decks
this is Mario chase I think from
Nintendo land blood alysha's in LA yep
flame beacon doobie guys we haven't got
color to play Portal 2 yet but portal 2
is one of my favorite games seem
emergent Solaris the other so to jump to
if you're close like what dives well you
can't do it as Mario do I do when you're
chasing you job ah no can't jump you can
only do it up sponge mac waves to bat
this mine I've never even heard go cam
chivalry is when a man open the door I
know it victim he said it's a video game
I don't know what here we are you
were funny all right I'm in green I'm in
green closing in
I'm in green closing in there we go I'm
coming I'm going towards a center close
neighbor the center by the red by the
red by the red in the center
wait there's color I'm getting close I'm
going towards rat and now I'm going is
that here oh wait he's close I see him
wait he's going towards I he's going
towards green he's in the mud going
towards green
I see a music green he's a green second
level he's at green top level green top
level green top level where is that I
just lost him I just lost him I mean I
just lost him where's he at
yeah he's in yellow you see in the
allegory towards red yellow going
towards red the mud
yeah he's in right he's in red I'm so
close how do you know he's right good
job he's in right
the mud is stupid that's the bud sucks
wait is that him over there guys I think
he's in yeah
no man come on guys we gotta get him
wait wait wait wait I see the green I
got him is it green go get up oh my god
is it great oh wait he's going back
towards green let's go back towards
green okay Bob no no no no you don't
give up I'm sucking them we need your
help okay it's the debt into good ground
what do you mean what colors what oh no
oh he's doing a dance you're the worst
the worst where's yet are you even
trying damn it
want a rematch you be at the sample I
think no man we got a duplicate I want
to get you again you're gonna get you
better win no more minutes baby if
you're just joining us by the way
Gabi Hannah from the gabbie show hi
finer on youtube.com the gabbie show
snapchat Twitter Google+ good amp up for
Google+ followers or what do they called
circulars what are the Google+ people
called the plus or I don't think anybody
you're up just followers I love it but
Gabi is about gie oh that's right Gabi
yeah Jaime bi eh oh somebody asked me my
favorite TV show um oh this is such a
weird one that nobody says I love her so
much
oh my god do you know do you keep the
tissues by you when you start the show
or do you just have to know I'm just
like really gross about it I'm like your
your head has grown natural natural
cloth I just let the makeup like three
or two - can we do an easier one should
we do one again yeah
we can do three I don't even know three
yes I've never played three I've never
played three no we do three I've never
played three slide hill I've never done
no never done this that's not good
favorite wrestler Styria lame-o Rey
Mysterio is great other rocks amazing I
went to a Smackdown thing once golden
guy Force uses Gabi I love you and say
hi to David that I said hi we can see
your comments oh okay
this is Alex and David where can people
see you guys by the way you have your
own they don't they don't get they don't
care see you on the Gabi's you can find
us on each channel exactly I got no this
is david dobrik this is Alex Cena Oh
everyone sings Cena John Cena I I'm a
fan of John Cena I guess yeah oh look at
this look at this I love it I love it
here we go oh you gotta go oh I like
thank you a little choco-chip you're out
I'm not I wasn't I'm going red wow this
is crazy green wow it was a foot away
from me wow you're great all right yeah
no I said whoever is green oh no I knew
where you were going I knew it I'm in
yellow headed towards red and I think
I'm close I'm close he's in red oh my
god you can't go up the thing let's go
up the middle of it oh jesus this is
tough no you can't
I've been blue in him close I'm getting
close I'm closing in on oh no no no
where is he at
so alright oh they don't I think they
turn two slides randomly I'm very close
I'm sliding down wait
is that no that's not very close in
yellow are you blue oh crap oh my god
there is it a Phatak here we go here we
go where is it dude where are you
you can't go back oh you're some kind of
magician this is crazy
Oh Oh crazy faces in between the slide
oh I didn't know he was under a bridge
probably I was so close okay I'm 23
yards I'm getting very close I'm getting
very close where you all color you can
play in blue blue blue
alright event turned blue no you see ya
at the bottom right oh that's you
oh my god the slide hill is ridiculous
oh I'm closing green I'm very very
closing yellow I'm a classic green
impulsive green posted great where the
hell was he I just saw him it must be he
must be between yellow and green is he
hiding it under bridge well this one's a
mess where's ya down here man oh god I'm
so far away that's embarrassing Nora you
should be you should be like I'm a
person who chases people oh I see him I
see him I see him
I'm sliding down the slide Oh God oh
there is I'm almost at him dammit I'm so
close
[Music]
ridiculous weren't worrying the whole
time God were you underneath them oh you
were just oh my god were you under a
bright feel like a couple times I slid
over you look how far away I am oh use
the slides really well use the slides
really well
oh look at that the double oh yeah oh
God use a slide so a man at the end that
was ridiculous you guys almost got me up
here by the green and blue soon how
about right there
actually oh man oh god you're so close
the slot it is really hard cuz you can
really get a boost far away so it's hard
to to get the yard is just jumps
immediately nobody would have caught me
on that okay right here oh that was
ridiculous darienne here let me get all
right I'll give it a shot let me try it
alright what one do we want to play what
level I lied when I assure you that runs
like an era Gaby cheats so much oh so
nice is Gaby's Star Wars or Star Trek
I'm Star Wars the reason is that the
chick that does vine clips on the gabbie
show online there yes it all rose I'm
gonna freak you guys out it's hot I
can't see it alright distracted now
green
whoever blue is go backwards I'm very
close getting further away I'm very
close you are yeah damn every direction
I turned I'm getting farther away
how that works now Green get away from
me it's like you in real life perfectly
defined our relationship he's at the top
yeah I know
I just don't know where
my guys closing on green or yellow him
there he is he's right here we're green
blue don't know he is now you're
very close I said I was close you're
going the wrong way
dammit Alex could have had him you're
such a piece of I know oh there he
is
where he's going up he's going up he's
going up I'm up it's going up but no
you're not that's not you okay now he
just changed its look go to red go to
red go to red I don't understand we're
ready
there is now he's going now he's going
up he's up he's up the top he's going to
the top he's going on the top how do we
all leave the top can I just like to say
look out of the top so we had like
nowhere to go close it on green
[Music]
we're all in the same spot damn it Oh
God have you so close the slides are
tough
cuz when you were I don't want it you're
over a row on the bottom of them oh my
god
I didn't get you I was pretty close to
you guys a couple times oh I know it was
a point was they like freaking like I
was trying to be followed my strategy
was I was trying to follow it so like
there is trying to follow you up but
then you would come close who is purple
me I love it they included this in the
game oh I know this is the best part
Oh see I should've just kept running at
that point I could yeah couldn't keep
two keys to town I think Alex should run
this house yeah you haven't run yet we
lose right away I don't think that's -
let's do it all
there we go or just a focus so we go
back to the first map yeah let's go back
to the first map let's go back to the
classics so yeah you just say yeah you
just end there right you're only gonna
look at Europe I use the joysticks yeah
oh yeah you only use the yeah the
joystick the two is just a job right -
yeah - yeah - is the dive Marxist Roy
says this game would be rocof is more
like a 3d mario platform instead of just
running I mean sure
maybe they'll make it on the next one
I like it itemized time to take a break
I do like how there we go up the nose
shot yeah perfect
alright so start running oh oh he
already thought green he's going towards
green yeah we'll have morgan freeman
come in the next monday melee actually
you know what I see Morgan Freeman at
Starbucks every once in a while which is
kind of funny that's one of the fun
things of working on this lot it's like
you see super famous people all the time
like me at Starbucks like you you see
Morgan Freeman oh my god I got him Green
Zack Snyder the other day that's really
funny oh that's amazing
that was awesome where did he go with
this weird bit where we say where we
talk about each other sneakers yeah it's
awesome he's the super nice guy he works
right over here he's gone greening ELQ I
mean look at my screen look at my screen
the top left I'm in green he's up there
he's going up top up top up top up top
here we go he's you know what when you
get to when you get the star you're
faster oh yeah he's in red he's in red
headed towards blue no man ran he's in
red headed towards right toward yellow
yeah I'm going towards yellow and I'm
gonna I'm gonna cut him off cut him off
the pass band that starts really helping
am I not oh I'm getting very don't play
smash Morgan we love you dude let's well
I'll pitch Morgan Freeman coming in
Freddie's mother
and Matt Damon what a nose Matty got him
knows I'm gonna go on the lookout I feel
like he's in red or he's in right he's
look at my screen I'm close I'm so close
purple keep going up straight purple go
right go down where is he where is he
Rosie look at my screen oh I can't what
were you which worse are you green great
where's look I'm right behind him I'm
gonna get him wait I'm in red now in
blue how do i sir come on you can't Oh
I just wasted a jab you just keep
following keep following it oh my god
Harry is here
ah we got it we got another one where's
he at where's he at whose right is that
you take Ronnie he's in Green bit closed
off to tackle him you sweatin Alex
where's ya
no no no middle middle middle middle
middle middle middle middle middle
middle going down in the middle so far
there's gotta be a way to like catch up
to him it's so annoying
no oh I got him I'm not worried about it
thought you went the other way and just
made him to go that way last jump I'm
totally oh damn it that game face
geotech let's see your game face you
have a tie game I was far I was far the
whole I was in embarrassment I was far
the entire time I've never been that
close to somebody that gave me I mean
like physically or emotionally I know
wait let me ask you a question about the
gabbie show how do you come up with your
videos are you have any videos in the
works now you're doing I steal all my
ideas from David perfect yeah are they
stole or do you give them freely he
pulls the strings no Alex the underdog
pulled off the miracles that's two I
want to go again against Alex yeah oh
man oh look at that oh my god oh my god
this asked me to close this one yeah do
the entire that's crazy
who is blue I know I tried but clearly I
was on the other side completely of the
things I was absolutely terrible say map
you're towards row oh you're though my
god you're throwing us in your tour it's
witty she's kicking that you forgot to
use the magic missile
what's the magic missile unreal a sure
bra stays better you got a prom with
yeah sure I think you should and let's
all tell I'll put a ghost put a GoPro on
your head and you can stream it you know
why don't we stream it live prom I think
you should
who wants Beth hashtag Beth prom if my
going here
Who am I alright I'm gonna get up on the
lookout Who am I Who am I who are any of
us really wait I think I see him is he
green I'm green oh you're in green
Mario's right come on man no no I'm
saying it well no sandal cast and look
I'm gonna go - I don't see he's probably
standing behind something that oh wait I
think he's on a blue top ring top ring
in blue headed towards green oh wait now
he's coming down he's coming down blue
he's in blue you see him yeah coming
down there we go here we go he's a great
headed towards the top headed towards
blue I think you went back towards green
[Music]
no how did do green going down a green
oh no I blew it around come on keep
following don't tackle just keep
following okay yeah because I want to
cut you off
oh I'm defeated unbelievable okay you
want to give it a shot you want to get
in here better ooh here now here you bet
you take mine are you so you take this
and give her the thing give her the
thing and then you take this you guys oh
man you got it you tried to camp out
that time it didn't play it didn't play
so well you know tried to camp out if
David was looking at my screen screen I
wasn't accurately in here in the game
that prom Asher is part going hard on
the Beth problem Asher explain your prom
strategy to Beth and maybe she'll go
where do you and where do you live and
what you being paired back
flame pika thank you for the update so I
just hit let's see this thank you for
the update on on Just Cause 3 I haven't
played it yet but I will
and what I did that would be incredible
I know I'm not sure how fast me she's
got long legs but you look on there you
look on there you only look in the
gamepad bet you only look in the gamepad
run away green green oh my god that's so
nervous
Beth only look at the gamepad dream
hahaha plot to his Asher is 40 there we
go she's out top of blue going back to
bets if you lose you're gonna go to prom
with a sure not to put too much pressure
on it
hey DJ mom Jane's good to see you by the
way how great a name is DJ mom jeans I
guess it's not good Aaron did you blend
join the brotherhood of steel I feel
like I should I only did that once I did
kind of join it but I haven't done
anything really on it you guys played
fallout Fallout 4 at all super fun oh
yeah oh my god here we go
Beth wins just for being Beth yes can
you show you better get that yes
is a sure Oh someone's going to prom
with
[Applause]
that way that videos alright one more
now wait who is the best
do we not who was the best I have a
blast yet alright let's go one more on
David you ready we're gonna take him
down I think we go I think we go slot oh
yeah yes I think I've ever said that
joining the Brotherhood doesn't matter
till the end I think that's was not a
problem when I was that says that was
horrifying beste wins in your heart
there we go
she wins in everybody's heart hey Oh Jay
EEM Wow answers on point with this we'll
see all right here we go this is for
everything uh Bandicoot I love Star Wars
Battlefront you guys like Star Wars
Battlefront love it love it it's so fun
you guys are into Star Wars right we
just got the oh no you were there I just
got to give up on Lucasfilm and his
personal vineyard whoa how was it
Star Wars wine um he makes his own wine
okay what it what is it called
what be a better name for Star Wars wine
probably what rhymes is wine in the Star
Wars universe I like try to concentrate
on like the names or like a funny play
on words I see em you think ello the
vintage is strong with this one I have
no idea start weeping don't cry cuz then
you can't see out your eyes I was trying
to cut them off that I forgot you can
see us
oh man I'm headed towards yellow I see
nothing at the top cocky cocky oh my god
oh my god the balls on this guy we gotta
get him you guys we have to get it I see
him he's headed towards the salary's in
the center now he's gone soon
let's go towards cream he's going
towards cream he's going towards green
green towards blue I want him so bad so
bad he's over towards blue god damn it
you're like faster when you're Mario or
something you got some code now he's
going towards red right here you
see him where is he where is he he's in
green headed towards yellow I see him
he's not he's going up green I said
towards blue I think he's where he's
headed towards you Gaby I think where's
yeah where's he's in greenies no now
he's down he's down look for the center
look for the center go to the center
where's the near the center going
towards yellow going towards yellow
god I see him I see him he's in green
thing towards blue come on get him no no
no no how is that possible damn it Oh
God he called out his colors he we
couldn't get him oh so angry I'm so
angry look at this oh you son of a
I mean well played well the end well
played I'll give it up I'll give it up
well played
yeah actually gonna get captured you uh
man this is ridiculous
that where this is just terrible playing
on our part you know he didn't win we
lost we lost it what happening I like
that god damn it look at this this is an
embarrassment ooh you juice me out I do
too you back what happened is the end
Alex you had him I have literally
glitched oh that was a mess my god well
that'll do it for today I want to thank
Gabi hannah and her friend Alex you see
Gabi on her show called the gabbie show
the GA be bie show on ya youtube.com
slash the gabbie show yeah every
episodes every week twice a week twice a
week my god by weekly bi-weekly week is
every two weeks so not bi-weekly twice a
week and these guys appear on her
channel as well and follow her on
Twitter Facebook Google+ Instagram
snapchat and all the other social
channels at the gabbie show and we'll
see you guys next week we're gonna try
to get Morgan Freeman next week it won't
happen and I sure enjoy your prom date
with battery right I love it thank you
see you guys next week of money
you